PEGI 12
does the color of the sky mean anything
special to you it does to me
a hell of a lot when I close my eyes the
sky in my dreams is a deep dark blue the
kingdom of arisia has declared war on
the oceans Federation I repeat
folks approaching fast in the rear in
the jailer know about the shitstorm he
was sending us into penal units are just
pawn what's with this guy
that's an su 30 we don't want to bet
with this guy all we can do is fly away
as fast as we can
so you simply watch things unfold from a
distance yeah I mean who would have ever
thought that I'd just go and follow him
straight into the enemy's squadron like
that
he really is foolish isn't he yeah for
one what's your status a little excited
figure taking the Beast head-on Makena
mark on his tail your defile this
country as long as you're here that
country will never know peace yet what
is a nation I don't even have a country
to call home
which path you would choose when looking
at Harlan's mean why are we made to do
this yeah I know I'm heading into hell
whatever adios you damn fool
ten seconds until the United attack of
the Arsenal bird
rumors of penal units turning on their
former allies rumours but kept the world
relatively sane up to that point had
been free-flowing david indefinitely
now is ricotta everybody give that the
tech everything you've got
what other choice do we have we go
their path for my mantra Tyson fight
stupid children
grandfather told me that
like you and every generation and I felt
every last one of them
hear me Genie meanie trigger did you
hear me all survivors respond can anyone
hear me that aircraft needs to be taken
care of can you hear me pilot with a
three-strike
you